[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
looking adaptable from the side just
don't look like lewis ck
i hope you don't take your dick out and
stop playing the drums
thanks buddy if you're an addict and you
want to keep it quiet
the road's the way to do it i mean
eventually you're going to make mistakes
and buy an
ounce of coke for an undercover agent or
you're going to get herpes or you end up
like mitch hedberg eventually that's
going to happen
yeah burton's poor bird leave
alone he's he's lifting weights with one
arm
a little chinese kid with a camera he's
walking around
he's walking around belgium and [ __ ]
like that i having a good time
i saw him last week he got so fat he
looks chinese i don't even know it was
burnt i thought it was a fine
i thought it was a fat [ __ ] and [ __ ]
and i looked and it was burnt with some
kid that alcohol is good
his [ __ ] head is swollen from those
budweiser
that [ __ ] tino's vodka he's all red
oh no
he sees a mess he's a man
i thought he was a fat [ __ ] i saw him
on birthday.com and
[Laughter]
my people asking me to do too much you
know all that
[ __ ] drains me like psychologically
mentally
well here's i know you just found
looking like reminded me of lewis saying
okay
why because you're looking like from the
side i don't know if you're playing with
your dick there
i don't give a [ __ ] if you play with
your dick i would never die that i want
to walk i'm not that type of rap people
have bad days and i'm saying yeah dude
i've had a lot of people grab my dick i
never complained one time no i know i
know fragrance to have a long you know
it's a long week for a fact they grab
your dick
they're just gonna squeeze and take
they want to grab your little stomach
one time and squeeze it what are you
gonna do you're gonna be mad
let it go saying prayer there's
something about people and they get
convicted of the right to have a power
over people and they walk over a room
[ __ ] like that dude
i gotta shake his [ __ ] hand
that one reminds me i told you okay that
reminds me of something you said
one time i had no idea what you meant
you said
you go black people eat to talk
and i go what you said i'm serious like
they
go that's right to eat to talk and you
said if somebody [ __ ] talks well i'm
eating
i'm gonna [ __ ] stab my neck but you
had a whole rant i don't know if you
if you even remember saying this a whole
rant about eating to talk
if i had never heard anything like it in
my
life it drives me [ __ ] crazy
he knows the exact story he knows why
you know the exact trend you know you
know what's
whole thing like a [ __ ] animal i ate
the whole thing
i kept calling him we're going out late
we're going to [ __ ] see the town at
first thing okay
call me back i'll be here like 10
minutes lately what's up you ready to go
[ __ ] i'm feeling [ __ ] up right
so i know he's going
down i call him back like in 10 minutes
he's eating sushi so
yeah he goes you know i'm getting a
little [ __ ] up
all right i give him another 30 minutes
i call him back he called me like eight
times in one day and also he's like
hello i'm [ __ ] up how much was in this
thing
i can't [ __ ] believe how [ __ ] up i
am i'm like [ __ ] it
get dressed we're going out [ __ ] i
hang up on him
right and i'm like oh i know and i call
him back and he's like hey
the phone rang like eight times yeah he
picked it up and i'm like where are you
i just puked i'm so [ __ ] high
don't blame it on the weed it's that
wholesale [ __ ] sushi you got from
that
he goes to this arabian boy yes you do
you told me
they got a dummy with [ __ ] hummus on
it or some [ __ ]
he does he goes to a wholesale [ __ ]
skates eight rolls for three dollars
yeah you're gonna [ __ ] die that's
like suicide we're just gonna
play tennis and i'll never forget one
day mitch hedberg gone
you know i'm picking a movement in new
york and i go i think that's a great
[ __ ] idea
and he goes well i go because everybody
in new york's like me
and you're like you don't even know the
moral of this [ __ ] story
i am [ __ ] the zoomer
look at how leah is so [ __ ] how deep
are you right now how many
no i'm just we ate two things that's 400
milligrams
a couple of stars of death lee's about
to eat one and two i'm okay
i think we're so are you ripped in half
though i'm not ripped in half i'm ripped
he's in training listen we call it
training yeah
you call it training did you guys do
october what did you guys call the song
of october yeah sub
october we do year round 24 7. i've
always loved kids anyway like i've
always i'm not michael jackson i'm going
to
invite him to the house no no but he got
a great adventure it was a great yeah
and then uh the the south americans were
all like this means you're gay
so they're like this means you won't you
want some dick in your ass you make the
okay symbol yeah
this has always been dick in your hand
yeah put a dick in my nose
if you're standing on the corner and
some guy pulls up at the light and goes
like this
yeah he's asking me yeah you want to
dick me in the [ __ ] ass for this
small 30.
he's giving you three fingers or the
small 300. when i grew up it was a game
like
if you got someone to see it you got to
punch him that was it was a game but now
yeah now it's
well who would you play these games with
i don't know other little [ __ ] [ __ ]
kids
this means [ __ ] in the ass yeah and
this means a flying [ __ ]
but now it means white [ __ ] power you
remember your first [ __ ]
yeah what was the guy's name joey
i don't know maybe i'm [ __ ] [ __ ]
maybe i'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] how old do
you have to be to drink
21. so you're giving a [ __ ] 14 year
old [ __ ]
pills because he tells you he's a woman
you're giving him [ __ ] pills it's
happening younger the mind is not even
developed yet
i'm not i'm not a [ __ ] genius here
i'm not a [ __ ] genius here
listen i did acid at 14. i may at any
time
walk into a [ __ ] restaurant and just
[ __ ] in my hand and throw it against the
wall
i'm waiting for it is dimension my
future it has to be
i ate 20 000 hits of micro that acid
let's pretend we're not even adding the
[ __ ] angel dust in there
before my little fat [ __ ] mind was
developed i know i'm gonna have a
problem down the line
i'm not a psychiatrist i didn't go to
doctor school i don't know nothing
but you're telling me giving a 12 year
old kid
[ __ ] titty pills [ __ ] pills you're
going to get some kid [ __ ] pills at 12
and not [ __ ] up his little mind did you
not know that that the
the fourth the 16 year old had to sit
and quote with his [ __ ] mother
because he's a [ __ ] he identifies as
a [ __ ] woman
but he's really a [ __ ] man if my kid
thompson
mercy comes home and says to me i
identify as a man i will start smacking
her what the [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying i identified as
a savage i still checked the box for
[ __ ] mail
okay i identify as a savage i rob people
i put people in trunks of cars i don't
give a [ __ ] i am a savage do you i still
mark the box gender
male i like to put other i'm a [ __ ]
savage [ __ ] animal
but you know how really you know how can
you
joey give your child they're doing it to
kids that are like
seven and six to give them titties to do
what yeah to start with
the what to transition like i'm no
[ __ ] genius here but i want you to
think about this
your little mind isn't even developed
come back when you're 24 oh you want to
be a woman come back when you're 24.
go out there and live like as a man
until you're 21. so you mean to tell how
would you have to be to join the service
18 18. i don't know maybe i'm missing
the [ __ ] boat no it's very maybe they
should put me in a [ __ ] mental
institute
you can watch hulu plus anytime anywhere
7.99 a month you're saying joey how is
that possible
7.99 a month you can watch on any
streaming [ __ ] device that you want
you understand me
on a smart tv roku apple
xbox pretty much any if it streams
you're [ __ ] watching hulu plus that's
how we work listen if you watch a
commercial with hulu plus
they're gonna give you what league
they're gonna give you two weeks
that's it uncle joey we go a step
further here on the church what's
happening now
if you put joey in the box j-o-e-y
you get two weeks for free and 7.99 a
[ __ ] month
so [ __ ] the 7.99 a month ain't doing no
favors when you run with uncle joey
you get two weeks for free huluplus.com
they don't [ __ ] around
smart tv roku apple
7.99 a month i'm offering my listeners
two weeks on the arms gratis you know
why
because that's how we roll all right
don't [ __ ] get carried away here i
love you guys hulu you know what shows
they got let me show you
the daily show family guy i want to
marry harry
gang related grow up fisher america's
got talent
last night with seth meyers they got
south park did you know about south park
they are keeping up with the kardashians
everybody hates chris
[ __ ] spongebob
they are everything that's how we do it
[Music]
huluplus.com
[Music]
just the wrong way